chris cuomo has been suspended
indefinitely by cnn as host of cuomo
primetime i am chris cuomo welcome to
prime time cuomo has hosted the nightly
news program for the network since 2018.
the network's decision arrives after
newly surfaced documents revealed the
extent of his involvement in building a
legal defense for his brother andrew the
now ex-governor of new york a cnn
spokesperson tells e.t in a statement
quote the new york attorney general's
office released transcripts and exhibits
monday that shed new light on chris
cuomo's involvement in his brother's
defense the documents which we were not
privy to before their public release
raised serious questions
and now to those new sexual harassment
allegations against new york governor
andrew cuomo tonight the state attorney
general is launching an investigation
after two former aides accused the
governor of misconduct
in the wake of andrew cuomo sexual
misconduct allegations earlier this year
chris admitted to cnn that he had
offered advice to his brother's staff
the network later publicly acknowledged
that chris had broken the company's
rules and according to the statement his
bosses at cnn quote appreciated the
unique position he was in and understood
his need to put family first in jobs
second
however new york's attorney general
released documents and text messages
this week which allege that chris may
have used his sources as both a
journalist and media personality to aid
his brother's defense and according to
cnn's statement on tuesday quote these
documents point to a greater level of
involvement in his brother's efforts
than we previously knew
as a result we have suspended chris
indefinitely pending further evaluation
thank you
for the honor of serving you
it has been the honor of my lifetime
andrew cuomo resigned as governor of new
york in august and i think that given
the circumstances
the best way i can help now
is if i step aside
and let government get back to governing
following this announcement chris gave
an on-air statement during cuomo prime
time i've told you it's never easy being
in this business and coming from a
political family
especially now
this situation is unlike anything
i could have imagined but you should
also know i never covered my brother's
troubles because i obviously have a
conflict and there are rules at cnn
about that
yeah they're always taking digs at each
other and it's hilarious chris cuomo's
wife christina spoke to e.t last year
about the brothers relationship
and it always provides for entertainment
at family functions and they love each
other to death i mean andrew uh really
helped raise chris he's 13 years older
than him uh mario was was off on the
campaign trail and matilda so
andrew was left with a little brother
you know to take care of so you know
chris learned a lot from him and uh you
know they kind of finish each other's
sentences it provides for a lot of
entertainment it's really nice that
they're sharing it with everyone else
now
[Music]
you